Générique
...
-Bonjour et bienvenue dans
"Politiques à table" sur LCP,
où on parle cuisine,
alimentation, agriculture,
mais aussi politique.
Cette semaine,
nous recevons Karl Olive.
-Bonjour.
-Merci d'être avec nous.
-Et avec moi,
Jean-Pierre Montanay.
-Bonjour.
Bonjour, Karl Olive.
-Vous êtes député Renaissance
des Yvelines depuis 2022.
Auparavant,
vous avez été maire de Poissy,
dans les Yvelines, pendant 8 ans.
Un parcours politique
entamé à droite, à l'UMP,
où vous adhérez en 2010,
vous soutenez Alain Juppé
à la primaire de 2016
mais pas le candidat
François Fillon.
Vous lâchez les LR
en 2017 parce que
"Wauquiez, ce n'est pas
"ma tasse de thé".
Vous vous rapprochez de Macron,
dont vous avez l'oreille
avec votre mouvement
Génération Terrain,
une ligne directe qui se confirmera
pendant la crise
des gilets jaunes,
où il vous consulte à nouveau.
Il aime votre franc-parler,
vous qui filez
la métaphore footballistique
pour analyser la politique.
Vous avez dirigé le service
des sports de Canal+ puis d'I-Télé,
d'où votre demande
d'un menu light et équilibré.
N'est-ce pas ?
-Même super light.
Du lieu jaune sans arêtes
pour monsieur,
légumes de saison
et en dessert,
salade de fruits de saison.
-Dans Le dessous des plats,
les députés sur la balance.
En moyenne, ils prennent
3 kg par an.
Comment faire pour ne pas grossir ?
Ils nous répondent.
-Dans Les pieds dans le plat,
halte au gaspillage alimentaire
dans les pas d'une association
qui récupère les invendus
des supermarchés
pour les redistribuer.
-On passe à table.
Tout de suite,
Cuisine et confidences.
-Je vous ai d'abord côtoyé comme
confrère sur les stades de foot
et comme joueur
sur les pelouses.
Respect des règles,
vision du jeu,
sens du collectif,
art du tacle,
vous avez vote compris
les similitudes
entre l'élu et le footeux.
Après avoir refait le match,
vous refaites la loi
dans une sorte d'en même temps
politique et foot. Le ballon
est souvent dans votre arsenal
et c'est sans doute grâce à vous
qu'en 2021,
le président de la République
a marqué un penalty
pour la bonne cause
des Pièces jaunes
face à d'anciennes gloires.
Mais dans l'équipe
du Variétés Club de France,
à 55 ans, vous sentez
que la bedaine vous freine
et que le moindre excès
se paie cash.
Tous vos amis,
de Vendroux à Platoche,
en passant par Vincent Guérin,
vous disent :
"Karl, muscle ton jeu !",
une façon élégante
de vous dire : "Arrête !"
Ce à quoi vous rétorquez,
souvenir de récré :
"Y a pas d'arête dans le bifteck."
Oui, mais y en a dans le poisson.
Cela dit,
votre menu light du jour,
poisson blanc et légumes,
sent le régime à plein nez,
tout droit sorti
de la cantine du PSG
en Ligue des Champions,
avec quand même cette précision :
"Un poisson,
"sans arêtes s'il vous plaît."
Pourquoi ?
-D'abord,
c'est plus facile à manger.
Je suis super heureux
de participer à l'émission.
-On est ravis de vous recevoir.
-Je jalousais
celles et ceux
qui partageaient votre table.
Je me disais :
"Peut-être un jour..."
Votre sollicitation
me va droit au coeur,
j'en suis ravi.
On me disait : "Muscle ton bide",
en fait.
-"Fais des abdos" !
-C'était "Voyage en ballon."
D'abord, j'adore le poisson.
Mais voilà, si on peut s'éviter
de s'en mettre un peu partout,
de retirer les arêtes...
Quand je demande une sole,
je demande
à ce qu'elle soit préparée.
Mais oui,
je suis un gourmet
et ça s'est vu
il y a quelques années.
-Vous avez toujours
mangé du poisson ou vous avez changé
votre alimentation ?
On reçoit plus de viandards
que d'amateurs de poisson,
d'habitude.
-Oui, et on parlera
du vin que j'ai choisi,
qui va plus
avec de la viande rouge.
Globalement, j'aime bien le poisson,
je vais tous les ans
en Espagne passer mes vacances
et on mange beaucoup de poisson.
C'est vrai aussi,
on en reparlera peut-être,
mais quand vous prenez
quelques kilos, il faut revenir
à la raison et ça fait du bien
quand j'essaie de transmettre
un bon ballon sur le terrain
ou que je vais courir
en forêt domaniale
de Saint-Germain-en-Laye.
-Vous êtes gourmand, gourmet,
les deux ?
Vous aimez bien la bonne chère,
les étoilés ?
-On était huit, dans la famille,
avec une maman...
-Six enfants,
une fille.
-Mon père voulait
une Nadia Comaneci,
il a eu une future présidente
du CIO
et une internationale de football.
Mais ma petite maman,
qui était fermière,
d'origine fermière,
nous a toujours fait
de la bonne bouffe.
On était comme ici,
un peu,
on appelait ça les auges,
autour de la table fermière,
et tous les soirs...
-Les produits
du jardin ?
-Oui.
Avec aussi, pardon,
mais les produits bretons.
Le kouign-amann,
les tripes...
-C'est un peu calorique !
-Il faut le rappeler,
pour ceux qui ne savent pas,
c'est un Breton.
-Oui, Finistère sud.
Je me suis marié à Belle-Ile-en-Mer.
Y avait pas que ça, y avait
le far breton fait par maman,
le clafoutis aux pommes
fait par maman,
le poulet à la crème fait par maman.
-C'est un peu calorique.
-Oui. Et rien ne restait
dans les assiettes.
-Pas de gaspillage.
C'est déjà peut-être
dans votre ADN.
-Pourtant, on sait
que vous mangez parfois
de la viande.
Sur ces photos,
on vous voit
à côté du barbecue
en train de cuisiner,
on regarde ça ensemble.
Est-ce que c'est de la viande ?
-Là, vous êtes allés chercher
des photos de vacances.
Moi, je suis un déconneur.
C'est à l'époque,
il y a six ou sept ans...
-Pas mal, le maillot de bain.
-Et vous avez pas tout vu.
Et donc, tous les jours,
je fais un petit plat différent,
quand je suis en vacances,
souvent en Espagne,
sur la Costa Blanca,
entre Valence et Alicante,
et j'appelais ça "Masterchèvre".
Et plus c'est gros,
plus ça passe.
Là, je cuisine
de la viande,
on peut faire de la paëlla,
de la tomate-mozza,
je mets ça sur les réseaux sociaux
et on me demande la recette.
-Tomate-mozza,
c'est pas très compliqué.
-Moins c'est compliqué,
plus ça intéresse.
-Les gens pensent
peut-être que Karl Olive a
un petit truc, une astuce.
-Un truc en plus,
une huile d'olive.
-Avec la petite
huile d'olive espagnole,
avec le gros sel à la truffe,
qui coûte pas plus cher
que le sel Cérébos.
-Les câpres, j'aime bien,
avec la mozza.
-Je mets pas de câpres.
-Pistou ?
-Non. Du gros sel,
un peu de pistou
de temps à autre
et un peu de coriandre.
-Ah, de la coriandre !
-Avec ça, vous ouvrez les narines.
-Ah ouais ?
-Oui.
-Je vais tester.
-Voilà,
une recette tomate-mozza
pas banale.
-Pas étonnant que ça enflamme
les réseaux sociaux.
-Alors, le poisson.
Vous faites attention
à la pêche durable, éthique,
qui fait attention aux fonds marins
?
Vous regardez, ou pas ?
-J'essaie d'être dans le cercle
vertueux de l'économie locale.
Par exemple,
quand on passait
nos vacances
à la pointe de Trévignon,
près de Concarneau,
mon père allait
pêcher le matin,
nous rapportait du congre.
C'est plein d'arêtes
mais c'est bon pour la soupe.
Ou des maquereaux.
C'était la cure de maquereaux
pendant un mois.
-Maquereau à la moutarde,
à la vinaigrette, au four...
-Mon père, un jour,
a pêché une lotte de 12 kg,
on en a mangé
pendant une bonne semaine.
C'est vraiment des bons souvenirs
qui restent,
et ça nous renvoie...
Je le dis avec émotion
car mes parents et mes frères
ne sont plus là,
mais ça nous renvoie
dans des moments,
je sens l'iode
et la plage de Trévignon,
le rocher de la baleine...
-Le barbecue,
c'est le côté mâle alpha.
Je plaisante.
-Je peux prendre
un verre d'eau ?
-Oui, vous pouvez boire.
Mais le barbecue,
c'est pas vraiment de la cuisine.
Vous aimez cuisiner ?
C'est la cuisine de votre maman
ou de l'Espagne ?
Vous avez
des inspirations ibériques ?
-J'adore les noix de Saint-Jacques
qui sont flambées.
On achète les coquilles
Saint-Jacques,
pas très chères,
et c'est de saison.
-On les voit,
vos noix de Saint-Jacques.
-La saison a été
très prolifique.
-Après Noël et avant
le jour de l'An,
vous trouvez sur le marché,
à Poissy, par exemple,
le jeudi et le dimanche,
des coquilles Saint-Jacques
à moins de 8 euros le kilo.
-Avant les fêtes ?
Souvent, ça monte.
-Jusqu'à encore la semaine dernière,
avant Noël,
on était à 4,90 euros.
-C'est pas très cher.
-Je prends mes Saint-Jacques,
je les nettoie
dans une petite passoire à l'eau,
ensuite, je les mets
sur un petit coton,
tranquillement,
et je les arrose de lait.
-Vous épongez.
-Non, j'arrose de lait.
Comme ça, ça les détend.
Une poêle bien chaude...
-Vous détendez la Saint-Jacques ?
-Je la détends.
Ensuite, la poêle bien chaude,
c'est le secret de ma mère,
petit beurre demi-sel...
-Pas d'huile d'olive ?
-Non.
Petit beurre demi-sel.
-Faut pas qu'il noircisse.
Et on snacke, juste ?
-On snacke,
aller-retour.
Après, vous choisissez...
Moi, parfois,
ça va peut-être vous parler,
je mets
du Noyau de Poissy,
une spécialité à base d'amandons,
à 42 degrés,
ou alors un peu de whisky,
et on flambe
avec un peu de crème fraîche.
Je sors ça, et derrière, vous faites
une petite tombée de poireaux,
un peu d'épinards.
Mes trois garçons,
Quentin, Hugo et Paco, adorent.
En général, à Noël,
on se fait ça.
-Tout le monde revient à la table.
-On sent l'expert.
-Je dis pas ça.
-Vous êtes aux fourneaux
ou c'est votre femme,
c'est à tour de rôle ?
-En général,
j'adore faire la cuisine,
mais je ne suis
absolument pas bricoleur,
et mon épouse est très bricoleuse,
donc on se complète aussi sur ça.
-C'est pas genré, chez vous.
-On va goûter ce poisson.
Attention quand même aux arêtes,
on peut toujours en avoir une.
-Pendant ce temps-là,
Jean-Pierre, avant que vous ayez
le temps de goûter...
-Ca passe bien, Jean-Pierre.
Vous en avez un peu, là.
Non, je déconne.
-C'est bon, Karl ?
-Oui, c'est bon.
-Je voulais parler
des poissons sans arêtes.
C'est quand même
le fait de ce déjeuner.
Les poissons sans arêtes,
je vous arrête tout de suite,
ça n'existe pas.
Mais il existe des poissons
avec peu d'arêtes,
avec de grosses arêtes,
faciles à enlever,
ou de petites arêtes
qui peuvent se manger sans danger,
comme dans la sardine,
qui a de toutes petites arêtes,
qui craquent un peu
sous la dent
mais qui peuvent se manger
sans aucun danger.
Les poissons avec peu d'arêtes
sont souvent...
J'ai perdu ma feuille.
Sont essentiellement
des poissons à chair blanche,
comme le lieu jaune,
le cabillaud, la lotte,
le merlan, la daurade,
mais aussi le bar, l'églefin,
le saumon et la sole,
qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'arêtes.
Les astuces, justement,
pour retirer facilement les arêtes.
-La pince à épiler.
-Sur un poisson cru,
munissez-vous
d'une pince à épiler
et arête par arête,
vous les enlevez,
mais c'est un boulot de titan.
Je vous conseille
d'enlever les arêtes
quand le poisson est cuit,
vous faites une incision sur le dos
et vous retirez l'arête dorsale
et normalement,
on a toujours
des petites arêtes
mais c'est comme ça
qu'on procède.
-Vous faites ça, Karl ?
Filet de bar. Magnifique.
Le filet de bar,
quand il est bien préparé,
vous le faites d'abord poêler
sur le dos, côté peau,
et une fois que la chair
devient un peu blanche,
parce que le bar est un peu rosé,
paf, vous le retournez.
Je vais vous dire, Jean-Pierre,
vous êtes goulu, je vois bien,
mais le filet de bar...
-Jean-Pierre a faim !
-Ca passe crème.
-Ca passe crème !
Vous aimez beaucoup
le poisson, et vous avez demandé
avec des légumes de saison.
Vous faites très attention,
jamais de féculents,
toujours des légumes, du local
et de la saison ?
-J'aime beaucoup
les légumes, et pour le sport,
vous êtes sportifs,
Brigitte et Jean-Pierre,
on en parle souvent,
les féculents avant la compète,
mais c'est vrai que les légumes,
comme ici les endives...
-Des petites endives braisées.
-C'est magnifique.
Mais une tombée de poireaux,
des légumes de saison,
du chou-fleur, du brocoli,
des haricots frais,
franchement, c'est formidable.
Oui, je prends rarement,
d'autant moins maintenant,
je prends rarement de féculents.
J'ai très peu de riz, pas de pâtes,
pas de pommes de terre.
-Même avant la course ?
-C'est différent.
Le matin avant de courir,
je peux me faire
une petite torsade de pâtes.
-Ah oui.
-Les pâtes, on comprend,
parce qu'il y a du gluten,
c'est des sucres lents.
C'est bon,
mais le gluten,
c'est pas très bon
pour la réactivité sportive,
on est moins tonique.
Mais le riz, c'est bon.
-Le riz complet.
-Oui, mais pas beaucoup.
-Vous n'aimez pas ?
-Si, j'aime tout.
-Quand on va
à Valence, on aime le riz.
-Oui, "arroz negro".
-L'arroz negro, la paëlla.
-Magnifique.
En fait, j'aime tout,
mais il faut être vigilant.
-Et les vieux légumes, aussi ?
Les vieux légumes :
les panais,
les vieux choux ?
-Oui, les bonnes soupes de panais,
c'est formidable.
-Les topinambours.
-Oui, aussi.
-Potimarrons,
potirons, tout ça.
-C'est des légumes nobles.
On a connu ça, en Bretagne.
Ca fait...
-Et l'artichaut ?
En Bretagne, on en a !
-Comme disait Coluche :
"C'est un plat de pauvre.
"Quand t'as fini, y en a plus
que quand t'as commencé."
-C'est vrai !
-Maintenant, on mange aussi
des petits artichauts
où on mange un peu tout.
En Espagne, en Italie,
même en Bretagne.
J'ai jamais su la différence
entre le violet et le poivrade,
mais c'est assez bon.
-Et le coeur d'artichaut
en tant que tel,
en vinaigrette light,
ça passe aussi.
-Dans les antipasti italiens, aussi.
Et les garçons, ils aiment
les légumes ? Souvent,
les enfants, c'est pas évident.
-Nous avons la chance
d'avoir trois enfants
qui sont très sportifs.
Le grand, Quentin,
a une hygiène de vie,
comme Hugo,
qui vit en Italie,
en Irlande, pardon,
à Dublin,
ils font hyper gaffe
à leur hygiène de vie.
Ils picolent pas,
c'est tout juste s'ils pèsent pas
leurs aliments.
C'est des grands compétiteurs.
Il y a quelques jours,
on a fait ensemble, en famille,
les 10 km de la Corrida
d'Issy-les-Moulineaux,
et le grand il fait
moins de 40 minutes aux 10 km,
il termine 30e sur 7000.
Il est footballeur professionnel.
Et Hugo, c'est pareil.
Il a perdu presque 10 kg
quand il a commencé
à faire gaffe. C'est important
d'avoir cette relation
à la bonne bouffe
dès le plus jeune âge.
C'est pour ça
que le jeune Paco,
qui est maintenant en 6e,
notre 3e garçon avec Céline,
il est aussi initié
à cette bonne bouffe,
même s'il a les envies
d'un jeune de son âge.
-Un burger, un hot-dog.
-Il peut, de temps en temps.
Il faut pas faire naître
de frustrations.
-Chez nous, y en a pas.
-Un bon burger,
une fois par mois...
-L'alimentation, ça s'apprend
dès le plus jeune âge ?
C'est une éducation ?
-Oui.
-Les sportifs boivent
peut-être du vin,
mais vous nous avez demandé
un vin un peu particulier,
un Saint-Estève, un Haut-Marbuzet.
C'est un bordeaux,
dans la région de Médoc.
Millésime 2017.
C'est du cabernet sauvignon 50 %,
merlot 40 %, cabernet franc 10 % et
un tout petit peu de petit verdot.
C'est un vin assez puissant,
assez épicé, avec des arômes
de fruits noirs, qui va pas
forcément avec le poisson blanc,
mais vous aviez une envie,
une anecdote à nous raconter
autour de ça.
-Moi, j'ai connu le bordeaux
quand j'avais 19 ou 20 ans
et que j'ai fait une pubalgie,
une inflammation
de la symphyse pubienne.
-Qui arrivent souvent
aux footballeurs.
-Très douloureux.
-Et quand on fait une pubalgie,
on est très limité
dans ce qu'on peut manger
et boire. On m'a fait goûter
le bordeaux et on m'a dit :
"Pour la pubalgie,
il n'y a pas de contrariétés,
"tu peux prendre un verre
de bordeaux de temps en temps",
et c'est ce que j'ai fait.
Et l'un des premiers verres
qu'on m'a servis, c'était
du Haut-Marbuzet, Saint-Estèphe.
Les spectateurs ne vont pas pouvoir
le goûter ni le sentir,
mais il a un petit goût,
si vous mettez le nez
un peu dedans...
-A consommer
avec modération.
-C'est une image.
Y a un peu de vanille.
Vous sentez
un arrière-goût de vanille.
Bon, après...
-Je n'ai pas votre nez,
mais je le trouve
très bon.
-Ca vous rappelle
des bons souvenirs ?
Ca vous a aidé à tenir ?
-Ca me rappelle un souvenir
où je déjeunais,
une fois par mois,
quand j'étais président
du club de foot de Poissy,
dans un restaurant à Poissy,
Le Bon Vivant,
près des bords de Seine,
qui était un restaurant
vraiment penché, qui servait
du Saint-Estèphe, Haut-Marbuzet.
Bon, c'est pas donné
mais c'est un très bon vin.
-Le Bon Vivant,
j'aime bien comme nom de resto !
-Un des vins
les plus populaires
de Saint-Estèphe.
On va voir si vous êtes
incollable, c'est le Quiz.
-Karl Olive, j'ose tout,
disons-le.
Difficile de faire un quiz
sans évoquer ce fruit homonyme,
l'olive.
Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations
concernant l'huile d'olive
sont vraies ou fausses ?
Il lit la première affirmation.
...
-Oui.
-Non, faux. Y a pas la queue,
y a le noyau.
-Ah, y a le noyau.
Il y a des pièges, Karl Olive.
Il lit la deuxième affirmation.
...
17e siècle.
-Vrai.
-Oui, vrai.
Notamment le savons de Marseille.
A cette époque, on n'utilise pas
l'huile d'olive pour la cuisine.
On l'utilise même en religion,
et surtout pour fabriquer
des savons bien gras
qui vont nous nettoyer.
Il lit la troisième affirmation.
...
-Faux.
-Effectivement.
C'est l'Espagne, qui reste toujours
le plus gros producteur.
C'était le grenier à huile du monde.
Il lit la dernière affirmation.
...
-Je vais dire vrai.
-Oui, vrai.
Y avait beaucoup d'oliviers
au début du siècle
puis c'est tombé en désuétude
et il y a eu une relance
et on est repartis,
on a replanté des oliviers
fin des années 70,
début des années 80.
Pas mal !
-Presque un sans-faute.
-Juste un truc.
L'huile d'olive,
dont on pense
qu'elle peut coûter cher,
l'huile d'olive qu'il faut aller
chercher en ce moment,
c'est chez Lidl.
Ca coûte pas grand-chose et c'est
l'une des meilleures sur le marché.
-On ne donne pas de marques.
-Parce que vos amis Espagnols
sont victimes
de la sécheresse
et l'huile d'olive monte.
-C'est vrai.
-Le prix monte.
2e quiz, vous qui ne supportez
pas les arêtes,
vous êtes peut-être fan de surimi.
Sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations le concernant
sont vraies ou fausses ?
Elle lit la première affirmation.
...
-Oui.
-Vrai, bravo.
Elle lit la deuxième affirmation.
...
-Faux.
-Faux, les années 80.
Ca arrive un peu plus tard.
-Juste un truc, Brigitte.
Le surimi, c'est sympa,
mais il faut le prendre
comme un Carambar
quand on était gamins.
Les petits bâtons de surimi,
ça se mange comme petit en-cas
entre deux matchs de foot
ou entre deux séances
à l'Assemblée.
-C'est pas de la bonne bouffe
mais y a du poisson et on est sûrs
qu'il n'y a pas d'arêtes.
Elle lit la troisième affirmation.
...
-Faux.
30 % de chair de poisson.
C'est vraiment reconstitué.
-Comme le colin d'Alaska.
Elle lit la dernière affirmation.
...
Vrai ou faux ?
-Ca me paraît gros. Je dirais faux.
-Faux.
C'est du paprika,
pour donner la couleur.
-4 sur 4, là, non ?
-Bravo.
-La carotte au surimi,
faut y aller.
Le surimi à la carotte.
-C'est juste pour la couleur.
Bravo, 9,
presque un sans-faute.
Vous êtes dans le top 5...
-Des meilleurs.
C'est souvent autour de la table
et à l'occasion de déjeuners
que se nouent
les meilleures histoires,
que se font parfois aussi
les deals politiques.
C'est La brève de comptoir.
Karl Olive, on vous a demandé
de vous souvenir
d'une histoire, d'une anecdote
autour d'un repas en politique.
Vous avez quelque chose ?
-J'ai deux anecdotes
qui sont de périodes différentes.
La première date de 1988,
j'avais 19 ans,
j'étais correspondant,
en plus de mes études
à la fac de Saint-Denis,
dans un canard qui s'appelait
le Paris-Normandie,
dans les Yvelines,
édition Paris-Mantes-Poissy.
1988, législatives,
et je suis
la campagne d'un monsieur
qui fera parler de lui après,
Henri Cuq, qui était
un très grand ministre
en relation avec le Parlement,
qui était élu
pour la première fois député
dans la 7e circonscription
des Yvelines.
J'y vais le soir des résultats
et Cuq, d'origine toulousaine,
me dit :
"Tu vas pas partir comme ça.
Chez nous, c'est cuisse de poulet."
Et donc, avec Henri Cuq,
on n'a pas trinqué
au vin, au pinard,
on a trinqué à la cuisse de poulet.
Et Henri Cuq me disait :
"Petit, dans la politique,
"très important,
le kir-cacahuète."
Ca m'est toujours resté,
j'ai fait un bouquin
où j'expliquais
la démocratie de proximité,
le kir-cacahuète,
c'est une des clés de succès
d'une élection électorale.
-L'apéro avec les administrés ?
-Vous en prenez plein la gueule.
On a fait 120 réunions publiques
quand j'étais maire à Poissy,
on préparait nos conseils municipaux
dans les quartiers,
systématiquement,
ça durait 3 heures.
Première heure,
les messages,
deuxième heure,
on échangeait,
et troisième heure,
le petit jus de fruit
et le kir-cacahuète.
-Ca détendait tout le monde.
-On se réconcilie
autour du kir-cacahuète,
du vin de l'amitié.
Ca, c'était Henri Cuq et ça a été
un très grand héritage pour moi.
Je le dis à celles et ceux
qui ont des velléités politiques,
je ne déconne pas, pensez à ça,
kir-cacahuète.
Alors, il faut faire attention
parce que bon...
-C'est ça qui vous a attiré
vers la politique ?
-Ca fait partie
des gens exceptionnels.
Michel Péricard, Henri Cuq,
c'est des gens exceptionnels.
Monsieur Juppé...
Bon. Le deuxième,
j'ai une affection particulière,
notamment par sa capacité
à faire rire,
à avoir beaucoup d'humour
et d'imitation,
pour monsieur Sarkozy,
avec lequel j'ai déjeuné deux fois
et qui est un chambreur
incroyable,
j'espère qu'il ne m'en voudra pas.
La première fois,
je suis porte-parole d'Alain Juppé.
Il imite Nicolas Sarkozy
"Ah bon ? T'es le porte-parole
"d'Alain Juppé, toi ?
Quel âge il aura en 2017 ?
"72 ans ?
Ca va être compliqué pour moi,
"Alain Juppé, 72 ans. Tu pourrais
me parler aussi de Valérie Pécresse.
"Qu'est-ce qu'elle veut ?"
Il faisait ça, il touchait
les verres comme ça.
"Qu'est-ce qu'elle veut faire,
Valérie Pécresse ?
"Elle veut faire Angela Merkel ?
"On va la mettre sur la plage
arrière d'une voiture."
Il disait ça
avec beaucoup d'affection,
et de se retrouver
autour de la table...
Y avait les verres
mais monsieur Sarkozy, président,
il est surtout chocolat.
-Il boit pas de vin.
-Pas du tout.
Il est très chocolat.
Au-delà du chambreur,
et je trouve
qu'on retrouve un peu
l'ambiance dans le vestiaire,
il en pensait pas une seconde.
Moi, je m'en prenais
plein la figure,
mais c'est des moments
qui sont franchement sympas
et c'est vrai qu'une réunion
à table fait que
c'est presque
de l'amortisseur social.
C'est formidable.
-On se réconcilie tous
autour de la table.
En politique, pas toujours facile
de garder la ligne,
c'est pourquoi il faut alléger
son assiette.
C'est Le dessous des plats.
Entre le début et la fin du mandat,
il n'est pas rare
de compter quelques kilos
en plus.
Le député est sans arrêt confronté
à la nourriture.
Quand il n'est pas dans un banquet,
une fête de village ou en déjeuner
dans les ministères, il accepte sur
le terrain les spécialités locales
offertes par les commerçants.
Un sujet de Maïté Frémont
et Dario Borgogno.
-Comment allez-vous ?
-Très bien.
-De gauche ou de droite,
de l'Aine, de la Mayenne,
de la Lozère ou encore du Loiret,
le député se trouve souvent
sur le marché de sa circonscription.
-Bonjour !
Richard Ramos, député.
Je ne vous connaissais pas.
-C'est ici qu'on discute,
qu'on échange
et qu'on goûte les produits
de notre terroir.
-Tartiflette, cassoulet.
-Je suis la députée
de la circonscription,
je viens vous saluer.
Ca sent bon, ici !
-Pour une matinée,
la députée devient critique
gastronomique et goûte
des pâtisseries marocaines.
-Ca, par exemple,
pour la ligne, ça va pas du tout.
Mais c'est bon pour le moral !
C'est très important.
Il suffit de ne pas abuser,
quand même.
-Garder la ligne.
L'exercice parlementaire ferait-il
grossir, madame la députée ?
-C'est pas les déjeuners
à l'Assemblée,
c'est plutôt,
globalement, quand on est crevé,
on a envie de manger
un petit carré de chocolat,
une petite sucrerie, etc.,
et ça, c'est ni bon pour les dents,
ni bon pour le poids.
Les députés
grignotent-ils trop ?
Retour dans notre placard
à archives.
-Dans l'hémicycle,
on a des casiers
et on s'approvisionne parfois
avant de rentrer en séance,
qui s'annoncent longues.
On a des friandises dans
nos pupitres pour tenir le coup.
Quand vous y passer 3 heures,
4 heures d'affilée,
parfois,
vous avez faim, ou soif.
Il faut sortir
ou le faire discrètement.
-Et si on montait sur la balance ?
François Ruffin a livré
il y a quelques années une anecdote
sur les réseaux sociaux.
-Une des solutions
pour garder ou retrouver
la ligne :
le sport, bien entendu.
Dans une salle de fitness,
sur un terrain de foot
ou encore en solo,
les députés l'ont saisi, s'accorder
du temps pour faire du sport,
pour le corps et pour l'esprit,
est primordial pour garder la forme,
qu'on soit politique ou pas.
-C'était un sujet de Maïté Frémont,
Dario Borgogno et Yvana Navion.
Karl Olive, quand on a une vie
de député parfois un peu dissolue,
avec des séances la nuit,
c'est difficile
de garder la ligne ?
-Je suis un exemple
de ce qu'il ne fallait pas faire.
2020, élections municipales,
trois ou quatre réunions publiques
chaque soir,
on termine à 23h,
comme le dit Violette à juste titre,
ma collègue...
-Violette Spillebout,
la députée du Nord.
-On est nu peu carbo, alors on prend
un petit coup de rouge,
le fameux kir-cacahuète,
un peu de cochonaille.
2021, il y a eu
les élections départementales
et régionales.
2022,
la campagne présidentielle
avec le président Macron
et les législatives.
J'arrive ici,
je pense qu'entre 2020
et 2022, j'ai pris 11 kg.
-Avant d'être député.
-Oui. Et je courais déjà
trois à quatre fois par semaine.
Ce qui veut dire que le sport
ne fait pas maigrir,
c'est une accélérateur, on reviendra
sur les vertus fabuleuses du sport,
mais si vous ne faites pas attention
à comment vous déjeunez...
-On vous voit sur ces images.
-Comment vous dînez,
à quelle heure vous dînez...
Et je me fais une double déchirure
aux adducteurs en jouant au football
et une déchirure
de la paroi abdominale.
-Vous êtes en carton !
Pubalgie, déchirure.
-Je suis en pleine forme,
Jean-Pierre Montanay !
A la différence
de certains collègues,
je fais un clin d'oeil
à Richard Ramos,
je sais pas s'il a déjà partagé
votre table,
mais c'est un vrai
critique gastro.
C'est le cordon bleu
de l'Assemblée.
-Son combat
sur les nitrites est important.
-Quand je suis arrivé à l'Assemblée,
ça a été l'effet inverse.
Pour le coup, j'ai perdu 15 kilos
en moins d'un an.
J'ai perdu 15 kilos
en renouvelant totalement
mon équilibre alimentaire.
Je rends à César
ce qui appartient
à Nadine de Théraform :
j'ai fait de la pressothérapie.
La pressothérapie,
c'est qu'on vient
vous mettre des points
avec un stylet,
tranquillement, partout.
Ca dure 30 minutes.
-Vous connaissiez ?
-Non.
-On nous presse la peau,
ça fait sortir la graisse ?
-C'est 30 minutes,
trois fois par semaine.
-Ca stimule quoi ?
-Ca restimule
les viscères, les points de transit,
y compris dans les pieds,
-C'est de l'acupuncture ?
-Non, ce n'est pas de l'acupuncture.
Il n'y a pas d'aiguilles,
on fait comme ça.
-Ca ne suffit pas à maigrir, si ?
-Non, mais ça,
c'est un catalyseur, ça accélère
la perte de poids et le fait de...
Il y a des régimes, je ne donne pas
les noms, mais vous perdez,
en un claquement de doigts,
en une semaine, trois kilos,
mais vous en reprenez cinq.
C'est le yo-yo.
Ici, non.
-Ca s'accompagne
d'une alimentation
équilibrée.
-Oui.
Tous les matins, prendre
le petit-déjeuner à la même heure.
Moi, depuis presque deux ans,
c'est un kiwi et trois tranches
de pain complet le matin,
sans grignoter.
Il y a des salades de fruits,
des légumes verts.
-Aucun grignotage,
légumes verts, le poisson aussi ?
-On peut...
Il peut y avoir des entorses
dans le régiment.
J'adore le bordeaux,
j'adore le kir.
Quand je suis en Espagne,
je fais attention.
Depuis un an et demi,
je touche du bois, j'oscille
entre -12 et -15 kilos.
Je suis en pleine forme.
J'ai retrouvé des temps de course,
je vais m'entraîner tout à l'heure,
où je fais les temps que je faisais
quand j'avais 30 ans,
c'est-à-dire
il y a à peu près 25 ans.
Pour le coup, le fait de faire
3, 4, 5 sorties
de course à pied par semaine,
ou très tôt, ou très tard,
et parfois la nuit,
fait que j'y ai trouvé
mon compte.
Je fais attention quand,
ce qu'on appelle le dernier rang
de l'Assemblée,
on lève...
-C'est vrai, ça ?
-Oui.
-Il y a des bonbons cachés
dans les casiers ?
Vous l'avez vu ?
-Je suis à l'avant-dernier rang.
On a des collègues de Bretagne
qui nous sortent
des bonbons au beurre salé.
-C'est quand ?
C'est en séance de nuit,
quand ça s'éternise ?
-Oui, oui.
Comme le disait la collègue
sur le rembobinage,
dans les archives,
quand vous passez 8 ou 9 heures
assis, sans bouger ni boire,
de l'eau, évidemment,
dans l'Assemblée,
je peux vous dire que ça s'ankylose
et que vous êtes content
de voir passer un bonbon.
On fait ça, c'est terminé.
-Vous avez quoi dans le pupitre ?
-Pour le coup, je n'ai plus
ces petits en-cas.
Je ne ressens pas...
Je ne ressens plus l'envie.
-Si ça passe devant vous,
vous le prenez ?
-Quand il y a une guimauve qui passe
ou des bonbons Haribo...
C'est très généreux.
Il n'y a pas
de sensibilité politique.
-C'est gauche, droite,
tout le monde pareil.
-Oui, on est "nous".
-Les collègues ont pris du poids ?
-Je ne vais pas dénoncer.
-Si, des noms.
-Non, mais...
Globalement,
les collègues font gaffe.
Je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
à l'Assemblée qu'on prenne du poids.
Comme le faisait Jacques Chirac,
quand vous faites un marché ou deux
par semaine...
-Comment on fait
pour refuser ? On vous tend
quelque chose à manger,
vous devez accepter.
-Vous prenez un tout petit bout,
et quand on vous sert une coupe
de champagne ou un verre de vin,
vous trempez juste les lèvres.
-Il n'y a pas des astuces
pour échapper au gavage ?
-Si, ce que je vous dis.
-Des petites quantités,
plein de fois, ça fait beaucoup.
-A table, on ne vous ressert pas
quand le verre est plein.
Il ne faut pas qu'il soit trop vide.
-C'est un peu
le combat de tous les jours.
-Je me suis dit :
"Je ne vais pas pouvoir récupérer
le poids que j'avais à 28 piges."
J'ai pu le faire, c'est un message.
-Vous avez retrouvé ce poids ?
-Oui. Je veux faire passer
ce message.
Les mecs et les miss, on se dit :
"On ne va jamais pouvoir maigrir."
Si, c'est possible.
-Ce n'est pas trop de frustration ?
-Non, au contraire.
Il y a beaucoup plus de saveurs.
L'appréhension,
le fait de prendre son temps,
de s'asseoir, de prendre son temps,
on retrouve...
-Une discipline, aussi, Brigitte.
Un kiwi et du pain complet
tous les matins depuis trois ans,
chapeau !
Il faut le faire.
Jamais un croissant ou une entorse ?
-Si, si, ça m'arrive.
-Bravo.
-Quand vous faites
cinq sorties par semaine,
entre 800 et 1000 calories
la sortie,
comme disait Coluche,
vous pouvez fumer sous la douche.
-Quand on fait beaucoup de sport,
on a faim.
On fait moins attention,
car on se dit qu'on a perdu
des calories.
-Je suis d'accord.
-Entre deux et trois litres
de flotte, mais pas trop.
Les fruits, les légumes,
ça fait que...
-Il faut une alimentation saine.
Le risque, aussi, OK,
on mange du poisson,
mais s'il y a une sauce,
qui recouvre tout le poisson,
ça fait grossir.
-Même si vous avez
la petite sauce...
Ca me rappelle les endives
d'un resto à côté
qui s'appelle Chez Françoise.
-Chez Françoise
nous a fourni ces bons plats.
-Si jamais, effectivement,
vous avez de la sauce
avec ce poisson blanc,
ce n'est pas un steak frites.
On n'est pas sur un steak frites
sauce au poivre.
J'adore ça aussi.
-Alors, 16 %
des Français, et là,
c'est autre chose,
déclarent ne pas manger
à leur faim.
En face, ce sont 16 millions d'euros
par an...
16 milliards d'euros par an
qui partent en fumée
à cause du gaspillage alimentaire.
On met les pieds dans le plat.
Musique légère
-Inspiré par Robin des bois,
au service des plus démunis,
l'association Robin.e.s des bennes
traque les invendus
de la grande distribution,
fruits abîmés,
conserves cabossées,
dates de péremption proches,
afin de les redistribuer.
C'est un reportage à Amiens
de Dario Bergoniaud
et Steven Martin.
-Une orange un peu abîmée,
c'est tout le sachet
à la poubelle. Une scène quotidienne
dans nos magasins.
Les grandes surfaces
de plus de 400 mètres carrés
ont obligation depuis 2016
de donner leurs invendus
à des associations.
Une bonne idée, pour cette
directrice de supermarché.
-Je trouvais ça important
de limiter mes invendus
et de les proposer à des gens
qui puissent en faire bon usage.
On perd toujours de l'argent,
mais, au moins,
les produits sont consommés.
-Bonjour.
-BONJOUR.
-L'association Robin.e.s des bennes
prend ces invendus
pour les redistribuer.
Elle vient 2 à 3 fois
par semaine dans cette enseigne
et ne repart jamais
les mains vides.
-On a des fruits et légumes.
On a des bananes,
ananas, des petits champignons,
des pommes, des patates douces.
On arrive des fois
chez des partenaires avec 3 caddies.
-70 personnes,
principalement des bénévoles,
aident les Robin.e.s des bennes.
3 % de la population d'Amiens
profite
de ces aliments censés terminer
à la poubelle.
-Allez, c'est parti.
Salut, Axel !
Allez, la belle récolte.
-L'association, créée en 2019,
a connu des débuts difficiles.
Certaines enseignes
sabotaient leurs invendus.
-On n'a pas pointé du doigt.
"Eux, ils mettent de la Javel"
ou "ils rendent inconsommables
leurs produits".
On a rencontré les directeurs.
On leur a dit :
"On fait vos poubelles,
"on sait ce qu'il y a,
"on les récupère
pour les distribuer."
Certains n'en veulent pas,
et tant pis.
Certains ont dit : "OK, ça faisait
longtemps que je cherchais."
-A la distribution,
on retrouve des personnes
en situation de précarité,
et ceux venus
pour des raisons écologiques.
-Notre volonté
est que ce soit ouvert à tous.
On ne demande pas les revenus
ou des conditions particulières.
Vous avez des personnes
qui ont des familles à sept enfants,
dans des conditions déplorables,
jusqu'à des médecins, des kinés.
Tout ce beau monde se mélange.
-Je suis toute seule
avec mon petit loup.
Financièrement,
c'est un gros coup de pouce.
Cette association
permet l'anti-gaspillage
au niveau de la récupération
alimentaire et financier.
Ca aide.
Si on achète,
on en a peut-être
pour une centaine d'euros
par mois.
Là, j'ai peut-être
économisé 20 euros,
facile.
-Les restes ne seront pas jetés.
L'association propose
un frigo partagé
ouvert à tous.
-On a mis un compteur
d'ouverture de porte.
On le met à zéro tous les lundis.
On est mardi, aujourd'hui.
Il a déjà été ouvert 72 fois,
ce qui est quand même
assez impressionnant.
-Les Robin.e.s des bennes
espèrent s'étendre prochainement
au-delà d'Amiens.
-Le supermarché dans ce reportage
avait pour obligation,
c'est la loi Garot,
de ne pas jeter ses invendus
et de les distribuer
à des associations,
comme on l'a vu dans ce reportage.
Vous aviez déposé
une proposition de loi
pour baisser ces surfaces,
et que ça soit la supérette
et le supermarché du coin.
Pourquoi ça n'a pas marché ?
Ca n'a pas marché avec les LR ?
Vous étiez avec Philippe Juvin.
-On souhaitait passer,
notamment avec mon collègue et ami,
Arash Derambarsh,
élu à Courbevoie,
de 400 à 200 mètres carrés,
pour obtenir 5000 points de vente
supplémentaires.
Je salue l'association montrée
à l'instant.
On a encore, aujourd'hui,
malheureusement,
des commerçants qui javellisent
les produits qui ne sont pas vendus.
J'ai pensé, adossé à l'exemple
de ce qu'on avait fait à Poissy,
sur une charte de l'alimentation
anti-gaspillage, de pouvoir
le proposer aux collègues
de l'Assemblée. On traverse
les courants politiques.
-La proposition est transpartisane.
-Oui, je l'ai encore ici.
-Ca a coincé ?
-Pourquoi ça coince ?
-Philippe m'a dit :
"Super idée, on y va."
10 jours après :
"Le groupe
"ne veut pas en entendre parler,
c'est porté par la majorité."
-C'est juste à cause de ça ?
-Il faut qu'on se détende ensemble,
plus que jamais
avec ce qui s'est passé récemment.
C'est quelque chose...
1 personne sur 10 dans le monde
a du mal à s'alimenter.
Brigitte,
vous le disiez tout à l'heure,
10 millions de tonnes de produits
sont jetés par la fenêtre,
c'est 16 milliards.
Par an, 150 kilos,
par an et par habitant,
dans les déchets, etc.
On peut faire cause commune,
on peut en faire
une cause nationale.
-Vous allez la remettre
sur la table ?
-On va la redéposer,
ça va se détendre.
Je ne stigmatise pas
les LR sur le sujet.
Ca a été aussi le cas.
Un jour, c'est tel parti,
le lendemain, c'est tel parti.
Faisons en sorte que le pays
soit le plus important.
-Vous ne le proposez pas
à Guillaume Garot,
un socialiste
qui est déjà allé dans ce sens ?
-C'est ce qu'on va faire.
On va travailler avec volonté.
On ne doit pas
se poser de questions
sur un certain nombre de causes
qui doivent transcender à la fois
les bancs
et qui font le large consensus.
-Sur le gaspillage...
-J'ai reçu une lettre,
je m'en souviendrai toujours,
en 2017 ou 2018,
d'un jeune élève en 4e à Poissy,
qui s'appelle Milo :
Il m'a dit : "A la cantine,
on a un certain nombre de déchets
"qui vont à la poubelle.
"Est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
les offrir à une association ?"
C'est comme ça qu'on a démarré
à Poissy,
et aujourd'hui,
le Secours populaire,
les Restos du coeur,
le Secours catholique,
après le Covid,
ont pu se saisir de ça.
-Ils viennent à la fin des repas ?
-Oui.
-Ils récupèrent
ce qui n'a pas été mangé.
-On a vu ce frigo partagé.
Maintenant, dans les cantines,
on a des tables partagées.
Si je ne termine pas
ma salade de fruits,
je vais la mettre
sur la table partagée.
Un de mes copains ou copines
qui souhaite reprendre
de la salade de fruits
va pouvoir le faire.
-Et tout le monde
a le Covid !
-"Tout le monde
"a le Covid."
-Non, mais...
Sans déconner,
ça fonctionne très bien.
Il faut écouter, encore une fois.
J'ai cette expression :
"Aller sortir le cul des vaches".
Il faut aller sur le terrain.
-C'est l'objet de votre association,
Génération terrain.
Vous partez du réel, du terrain.
C'est comme ça
que vous faites de la politique.
-On parlait de sports.
Vous avez entamé l'émission,
je vous en remercie,
sur l'apport du sport
dans la gestion au quotidien
des collectivités publiques.
Dans le sport,
vous êtes imbibé aux règles.
Personne au football
n'aurait l'idée
de faire une touche au pied.
Vous êtes dans le jeu
ou hors du jeu.
En politique,
on rappelle les règles.
Les règles,
on ne les interprète pas,
on les applique.
Ca m'a beaucoup apporté.
-C'est une règle de vie ?
-Oui. Les deux heures de sport
que je donne aux agents,
par semaine,
sur le temps de travail
à Poissy en 2017,
ce n'est pas car j'aime le sport,
c'est que je crois
aux vertus du sport.
-C'est du collectif, alors ?
C'est un sport co ?
-Bien sûr.
Il y a marche, marche nordique,
nage, nage avec palmes, relaxation.
Aujourd'hui,
on a de la chorale, 16 créneaux
différents dans la semaine.
-Sur les heures de travail ?
-Oui.
Il n'y a aucune catégorie.
-Il y a moins de maladies,
ils sont plus en forme.
-On est passés
de 20 jours par an par agent
à 16 jours par an par agent.
2 millions d'économies,
baisse de l'absentéisme.
C'est des choses concrètes
qui viennent du terrain.
C'est validé.
-Une petite idée
pour votre proposition de loi.
J'ai remarqué
que 14 % des restaurants
jetaient, gaspillaient.
Y a-t-il moyen
d'aller récupérer, peut-être,
ce qui n'a pas été mangé ?
-Vous avez des restaurants
qui jouent le jeu,
qui n'ont pas besoin de loi
pour pouvoir le faire,
y compris des commerçants.
J'en connais
à Poissy, à Orgeval, la crêpière,
à Plaisir.
-Il ne faudrait pas les inciter ?
-Ce qui est bien,
c'est que l'incitation permet
de garder une latitude.
Il ne faut pas emmerder
les Français.
Si on leur dit :
"Vous allez pouvoir distribuer,
"mais premièrement, deuxièmement..."
Ils vont dire :
"Si on peut éviter
de faire compliqué
"quand on peut faire simple..."
L'incitation est belle.
Encadrée, c'est mieux.
Ce sera l'objet de cette loi.
-Se rapprocher des assos,
faire un lien
avec les restaurateurs.
-Ca arrive.
On a à la fois
des déchets biologiques et ménagers
au sortir des cantines.
Ces déchets,
on a 2600 repas servis à Poissy
par jour,
les déchets biologiques
sont ramenés par une association
qui s'appelle Tryon,
à Carrières-sous-Poissy,
dans un immense compost,
et derrière,
on peut faire de la biomasse.
-J'ai une question technique.
On l'a vu, les oranges abîmées,
c'est facile, on les redistribue,
il y a des bananes
abîmées, on les mange,
les conserves aussi.
Un autre sujet,
c'est les dates de péremption.
D'ailleurs, ils n'ont pas
voulu parler sur ce sujet-là.
Comment on pourrait faire une loi
pour pouvoir redistribuer
ces produits qui ont passé
la date de péremption ?
-Qui sont mangeables.
-Evidemment.
Par principe de précaution,
on les jette.
Il y a des raisons sanitaires
qui sont derrière.
Quelqu'un peut porter plainte
car il a mangé un yaourt
qui avait six mois.
Comment on peut encadrer ça
par la loi ?
-Vous avez raison.
Deux exemples :
Alexandre Bompard, Carrefour,
Michel-Edouard Leclerc, Leclerc.
Ca se passe
sur des délais
de limite de consommation.
Le yaourt
que vous allez manger aujourd'hui,
il est en péremption
dans 3 ou 4 jours. La vérité,
c'est que si vous le savourez
un ou deux mois après
et qu'il ne sent pas
la fermentation,
vous n'allez pas avoir
de saignement de nez.
Pas de machine
à courber les bananes.
-On est quand même obligés
de laisser
une date indicative.
-Oui, mais typiquement,
à Carrefour
ou dans les centres Leclerc,
c'est ce qui se passe.
Chacun prend ses responsabilités.
Voyez-vous, si c'est...
Simplement, ce qui est paradoxal,
en politique,
c'est qu'on veut faire moins
de lois, mais on en fait plus
et les anciennes
ne sont pas appliquées.
On va sortir
le décret d'application,
ça nous fera du bien
à toutes et à tous.
Je crois au pragmatisme, vraiment.
S'il y a des exagérations,
il faut faire des contrôles
inopinés.
Faisons des contrôlés inopinés.
Si, avant le mot "défiance",
on peut se faire confiance,
on va en faire, du chemin.
-J'ai regardé, en Europe,
la France est dans la moyenne
européenne au niveau
du gaspillage.
Le pire élève est la Norvège.
Après, le Royaume-Uni. Il faudrait
une politique européenne ?
-Commençons par balayer
devant notre porte
et saisissons-nous
de ce qu'on peut mettre en place.
Quand je prends l'exemple
de ce jeune homme de 14 ans
qui m'envoie une lettre
pour me dire :
"On pourrait faire ça."
Non seulement on l'a fait,
mais on l'a décliné
sur l'ensemble des écoles
à l'époque.
Ensuite, on a quelques
restrictions, car aujourd'hui,
ce n'est pas le sujet
d'avoir plus de bouffe,
dans les associations caritatives,
c'est d'avoir de la bonne bouffe.
On peut avoir des sales gueules.
Ces fruits qui sont un peu tachés,
c'est bon.
Ce n'est pas le sujet.
Ce n'est pas
en avoir plus,
c'est "en avoir mieux".
On a signé cette charte
du gaspillage alimentaire
vers le zéro déchet
avec Arash Derambarsh,
Ca a fait école, et tant mieux.
Ca vient du terrain.
-Il en faut plus aussi.
On a vu les Restos du coeur
qui refusaient du monde
car il y avait du manque.
-Et une capacité, Brigitte Boucher,
ça ne vous a pas échappé,
logistique,
de pouvoir entreposer
ces denrées alimentaires.
-Merci les associations.
-Bien sûr, merci
les associations. Les associations,
encore une fois, c'est un viatique
pour rendre la vie,
le bien vivre ensemble.
-Vous dites :
"Je suis un enfant de Coluche."
C'est à lui que vous devez ce combat
pour la lutte anti-gaspi ?
Vous citiez une blague,
tout à l'heure.
C'est votre maître en matière
d'humour et d'anti-gaspillage ?
-J'ai grandi avec Coluche
et j'ai eu la chance de faire
quelques trucs avec lui.
C'est vrai que, malheureusement,
quelques mois avant son décès,
il crée les Restos du coeur,
tout le monde se marre
en disant que c'est une connerie.
La vérité, c'est que ça existe
encore et que ce sont des assos...
-Ca marche très bien aujourd'hui,
ce n'était pas le but.
-Il ne faut pas les monter
les unes contre les autres,
et surtout pas les associations
contre l'Etat.
On dit : "Les Restos
font ce que l'Etat ne fait pas."
Ce n'est pas
ce que souhaitait Coluche
ni ce qu'il disait. Coluche
a apporté sa pierre à l'édifice,
Il faut continuer à soutenir,
leur apporter un soutien logistique,
financier, matériel,
mais tous les bénévoles
qui sont aux Restos du coeur
comme dans toutes les associations,
car elles sont très nombreuses,
on devrait leur décerner
le prix Goncourt.
-On a fini, je vous vois lorgner
sur le dessert.
C'est Le péché mignon.
-Voilà ce que c'est d'inviter
un homme politique
qui fait un marathon demain.
Pas de saint-honoré,
pas de paris-brest.
On a une salade de fruits de saison.
Je suis un peu déçu.
C'est normal, avec son pain complet
le matin, son kiwi et sa salade
de fruits de saison. Il y a
quand même une toute petite...
Non pas une trahison,
mais il y a des ananas, des mangues,
ce sont des fruits de saison,
mais à quelques milliers
de kilomètres.
Ca vous dérange ou vous achetez ?
-Bien sûr que j'achète,
et je consomme.
Je vais vous le dire :
sans état d'âme.
On va arrêter ça.
-Il y a une trace carbone.
On ne peut pas passer outre.
-D'accord,
mais attendez, allons-y.
On a une trace carbone.
La France
est un des meilleurs élèves
en matière
de transition écologique.
Qu'on arrête de nous emmerder
au quotidien, savourons
une bonne petite salade de fruits.
Ca fait du bien,
ça nous permet d'être en forme
et ça fait travailler.
-Jamais de dessert,
jamais une petite entorse,
un gâteau au chocolat ?
-Très honnêtement,
très honnêtement...
-Vous n'êtes pas sucré ?
-Non, mais je me suis mis
aux salades de fruits,
et disons les choses :
à l'Assemblée,
dans les cantines,
les agents du personnel
où j'adore aller manger au self ici,
c'est formidable.
Est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment d'avoir fait
un repas de régime ?
-Non. Jean-Pierre, peut-être.
-Non, non.
Reconnaissons cela,
on a fait un repas sain.
On sent que c'était sain,
ce poisson, ces endives,
on ressort de là léger.
C'est un menu sain.
-Et vous n'allez pas avoir
de coup de barre, cet après-midi.
Vous n'avez pas de profiteroles,
avec des chocolats, plus de chocolat
que de profiteroles.
Non, là, on est "up-to-date".
On est parfaits.
-Vous ne vous forcez pas.
Vous n'êtes pas trop dessert.
Vous avez adopté cet équilibre.
-Hm.
-D'accord.
On termine toujours
cette émission en musique,
mais comme on vous a déjà vu,
sur les réseaux sociaux,
pousser la chansonnette,
je voulais savoir
si vous accepteriez de chanter.
Vous choisissez.
Si vous acceptez, vous choisissez.
-Je vais vous dire un truc.
Je suis un mec sérieux
qui ne se prend pas au sérieux.
J'ai une relativité à la vie
qui est
assez exacerbée par rapport
aux malheurs qu'on peut connaître.
Quand, au moment du Covid,
car depuis 2014,
je chantais une fois par an
au banquet des anciens à Poissy,
au moment du Covid,
des personnes âgées m'ont dit :
"Monsieur le maire,
"on est enfermés, confinés.
Pourriez-vous
"faire une petite chanson
tous les jours, à 16h, au goûter ?"
Je me suis dit : "Putain, KO,
"tu ne vas pas faire ça ?"
Ca leur faisait plaisir...
-On vous a vu avec les anciens.
-J'en ai fait une fois,
je l'ai fait deux fois,
et j'ai fait 120 chansons.
Les gens sont très contents
Je ne vais pas faire "The Voice"
ni l'Eurovision,
mais je suis heureux.
Si tous ceux qui me rentrent dedans,
comme c'est le cas,
comme disait ce fameux écrivain :
"Si ceux qui disent du mal
de moi savaient
"mes pensées,
ça serait pire."
Je suis heureux de partager ça.
Je vais vous interpréter
une petite chanson
de Pierre Bachelet, qui date
de 1988. J'avais 19 ans,
c'est ma petite maman
qui aimait beaucoup cette chanson,
qui s'appelle "Souvenez-vous".
Y avait des arbres
et y avait des oiseaux
Le blé devait se moissonner bientôt
C'est tellement beau l'été
Qu'on peut pas croire
Que c'est la guerre
qui fait marcher l'histoire
Souvenez-vous
Je n'aimais que vous
-Magnifique !
Belle voix !
-J'en ai d'autres.
-Vous avez un répertoire
très large.
Celle que vous aviez choisie,
c'est une musique de Michel Fugain.
On l'écoute
pour terminer l'émission.
*"Chante", Michel Fugain
*...
-CHANTE LA VIE CHANTE
COMME SI TU DEVAIS MOURIR DEMAIN
-Pourquoi le choix
de cette chanson ?
-D'abord, Fugain chante des chansons
qui rappellent des souvenirs,
comme Delpech, qui nous renvoient
dans des souvenirs,
de la traçabilité,
"Chante, chante,
comme si tu pouvais mourir demain".
Profitons de la vie.
-Comme si on pouvait mourir demain.
C'est votre philosophie de vie ?
-Exactement.
-Merci d'avoir partagé
cette émission avec nous.
Merci à Chez Françoise
de nous avoir fourni ces plats
sains, légers, light, équilibrés
et de saison.
Merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis.
On se retrouve bientôt
sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA